joining us now from the kalonian stitute
for economic research is Holger Shaffer
mr. Schaffer first of all is this going
to be a job destroyer or could it be
seen as a stimulus measure well I don't
subscribe to the idea that the minimum
wage could be a boom for the economy
because this additional money the
exemplary scared has to be paid for
either by the employers with less money
for consumption for themselves or for
less money for investment or by the
consumers who have to pay higher prices
so not a boom that could be a boost in
in any sort of way I mean it would mean
pumping more money into the economy
wouldn't it yeah if you refer to to the
monetary system then it could be the
case but I think introducing minimum
wages that certainly is the wrong way to
manage zzzzz financial issues here at
hand I think that is a matter that
should be addressed by the ECB and when
you're talking job losses how many job
losses here in Germany we're talking
about a big economy yeah there are
several different estimates about the
job losses that's reached from zero no
negative impact up to almost 1 million
job losses but of course we have to
consider that the minimum wage is only
one factor in labor market development
for the next year we hope that level
market runs pretty well and the next
year so all these factors could maybe
compensate the negative impact of the
minimum wage and why is so many job
losses I mean is that simply the the way
that people some companies are going to
have to take is that going to be there
direct reaction to the minimum wage I
think others have to be economical if
for example the taxi driver doesn't have
enough turnover to pay for his own
minimum wage in addition to the other
costs like like gasoline or insurance
payments then his workplace is an econo
Michael and certainly in danger of being
laid off but what about the low paid
workers it's a growing army as we
mentioned here in Germany of low-paid
workers doesn't the government have to
do something I mean state intervention
isn't always the answer but surely these
workers have to be protected in some way
if you want to a higher
earn higher wages and you have to earn
more value-added buy from your work and
so you have to have higher
qualifications to earn more money that
is the key to to higher wages and so
what are you saying that low-skilled
workers basically a set to stay there
they have to do something to get
somewhere well if low-skilled workers
low wages then they have to acquire more
skilled soldier you can earn higher
wages okay we're going to get back to
more on this and the effects of the
minimum wage in a moment first let's
have a look at how the minimum wage has
gone down elsewhere in the world or in
many cases gone up that's what's being
debated right now in Brazil and the
United States raising the minimum wage
it's just been done in Poland it first
introduced the regulation over a decade
ago though a good opportunity for
neighboring Germany to take heed of some
of the pitfalls many Polish companies
have come up with ways of evading the
system for baa bahoo aur then yet
supporting her family is a challenge she
works as a cashier but doesn't even earn
minimum wage what's real opponent that I
work full-time in the supermarket and an
only 1200 [ __ ] or 400 euros a month
feeling resentment I work for a
subcontractor and they treat us like
trash dr. Vaughn you should not let
people well then yet isn't a regular
employee she has what's called a work
contract a work contract means that a
person is being paid to create a
specific product for example an
advertising brochure they're paid for
the product not an hourly wage
but there are some legal loopholes
supermarkets for example use
subcontractors instead of paying an
hourly wage the subcontractors hire
cashiers using work contracts so the
cashiers are classified as self-employed
and don't get minimum wage health
insurance or pension coverage many
security staff and cleaning personnel
are hired under work contracts at large
supermarket chains also tend to exploit
this legal loophole the staff have no
job protection and rarely earn more than
400 euros a month unions have long been
fighting to change this practice but
here in Poland it's still common in
companies such as leader and lo dico
movie estes trash news the retail
industry has a lot of these work
contracts pratts ooh yeah about forty
percent of retail employees have work
contracts which I Nissan normally
they're not employed by the stores
themselves feel may haven't fatigue on
their out sourced or hired through
outside firms the labor market in Poland
has about 16 million workers almost a
third are in what's called the gray
market with short-term contracts and
poor labor conditions 1.6 million have
only a work contract and their numbers
are on the rise the polish employers
federation says the minimum wages to
blame but the minimum wage in poland is
less than 2 euros 50 per hour the
Kshatriya pukas whoo yeah our experience
has shown that when the minimum wage is
more than forty percent of the average
wage in the region then companies start
to dismiss poorly qualified workers also
on uski quite a few cuts yet then they
rehire them through different mechanisms
including the gray market for example a
taste if the grey market in Poland is on
the rise and so our work contracts that
pay less than minimum wage after the
boom of you
years ago the Polish economy has now
stabilized in 2014 the gross domestic
product increased by three-point-three
percent but unemployment in Poland is
over eleven percent that's part of why
people like ba ba ba or then heads are
forced to take poorly paid work
contracts you have no choice I have to
take a work contract and companies take
advantage of people at me yugioh kill
she barely earns enough to support her
family I can't pay all my bills I need
to buy food for my children for people
like Barbara or Dan yets the minimum
wage would be a major improvement mr.
Schaffer is that all the result of the
minimum wage in Poland no I don't think
so because I think this is a major
result of the legal framework of the
labor market in Poland after all there
are many European countries who have
minimum wage and not all these countries
have these kind of problems exactly the
minimum wages is nothing new here in
Europe it just varies radically Bulgaria
for example if we take a look at the
hard hard figures it's it's only the
equivalent of just over a euro well of
Luxembourg on the other hand officer
generous 11 euros 10 I look at France is
surprising considering Germany's
offering less and is in a much better
financial position but I suppose you
have to compare it to the average wage
then don't you exactly that is important
factor is the minimum wage in relation
to the average wage and then it's quite
high in Germany and this respect Germany
is quite high on the list together was
France and France is a country who has
some problems with the minimum wage
other than for example the United
Kingdom what are the problems in France
France we have a very high youth
unemployment and we have even state
subsidies for young
employed who have to be have to those
have to be paid a minimum wage but the
firms are not able to pay this and so
they are government subsidies and this
is not a quite good idea to pay
government subsidies for a wage that is
imposed by the government itself ok
we'll get to youth unemployment in a
second with the UK they introduced the
minimum wage back in 1999 they painted
all sorts of horror scenarios but they
didn't come true did they oh the united
kingdom was much more clever in
introducing than minimum wage they're
aware did it too right they had a low
level of the minimum wage in the first
phase and they installed a committee of
economists who monitored all the effects
of the minimum wage and who set the
level of the minimum wage in the
following years and this is much more
cleverly than doing this by politicians
okay well let's see if Germany can learn
from its neighbors mistakes and also the
good things its neighbors have
introduced mr. Schaefer good to have you
on the show